what is the definition of life
for a long time people have thought that
we've worked out all the ways that life
can exist on this earth
there's the plants the fungi the
multicellular animals the archaea the
bacteria and the protists but this
particular creature doesn't fall into
any of these categories and its
existence has sparked one of the
greatest debates in modern science if
you were to observe these organisms
under a microscope you'd see them propel
themselves around moving forward
backwards sometimes spinning in a circle
if you were to scatter some particles
around them they will round them up and
make little piles organizing the debris
their motion and behavior even resemble
that of other microscopic organisms they
are motile can heal damage retain
information and even work together but
these organisms were not born out of
millions of years of evolution they were
instead designed by computers and built
by human hands
xenobots as they are called are
synthetic life forms or living robots
and consist of two things
skin cells and heart cells from the frog
xenopus lavis after which they are named
they are the first man-made organism and
an entirely new type of living system
and one day scientists hope that they
will help us monitor radioactivity
combat pollution or even cure disease
when they were first created xenobots
were already testing the boundaries of
how we define life but then something
truly startling happened they started to
spontaneously reproduce making new
copies of themselves in a way that
science has never observed before
how is it possible for scientists to
create a new type of life form and why
did they in the first place
how will these tiny creatures one day be
of great use to us and what can they
tell us about the nature of life itself
sometimes called soft robotics the field
of biorobotics is a relatively new one
much like classic robotics it aims to
solve human problems by constructing
machines but instead of using steel nuts
and bolts the key raw material for
biorobotics is living tissue it's a
discipline that integrates biology with
mechanical design bio hybrid robots are
generally composed of muscle tissue
either cardiac or skeletal and an
artificial scaffold and the benefit of
using biology in robotics is substantial
biological components have unique
characteristics that artificial
materials can't exactly replicate their
greater flexibility enables them to move
more like living organisms than machines
they can also quickly and naturally
respond to external stimuli
some could even heal from damage or
injuries
artificial structures are also prone to
entropy the gradual decline into
disorder the crumbling of concrete the
rusting of metals the breakdown of
plastics
but living organisms are in a constant
battle against entropy
they preserve their internal order by
taking energy from their surroundings
this quality alone could allow biobots
to far surpass the useful lifetimes of
even our best artificial technologies
one of the earliest examples of soft
robotics is this creation made in 2014
it's composed of a plastic backbone
surrounded in heart muscle tissue from a
mouse
by pulsing current in the liquid media
at different frequencies the muscle
cells are told to contract and the
biohybrid is made to walk albeit in a
very jerky way
a year later this idea was refined this
time using sea slug mussels
this biohybrid was designed after a sea
turtle so it can move more easily
through its aquatic environment
other biorobotics focus on articulation
aka a robot that has arms or legs that
can be used to manipulate its
environment
this biohybrid is an articulated limb
with muscle tissue attached to an
artificial backbone
by changing the voltage on the left or
right side the muscles compress or
contract causing this articulation that
can be used to pick things up or move
things around
this biohybrid was inspired by a
jellyfish
it uses an artificial scaffold with
layered heart tissue on top of that
the biohybrid moves in a very similar
way to a real jellyfish
and more recently scientists have
created a light controlled stingray
it's a stingray shape made out of an
artificial backbone that is layered with
rat heart muscles
instead of being directly activated by
electricity these muscle cells have been
programmed to be activated by light
this way you can drive the robot around
by shining lights on either the right or
left hand side but for all these
machines to work outside input is needed
for them to know how to behave
electricity or light supplied by a human
plus the artificial components can break
and if used in the environment are not
biodegradable and in the body not
biocompatible and the biological
components are being used just as an
actuator they are just providing the
machine with motion as a motor would
but cells can do so much more than just
contract
there's an entire world of innate
behavior and rich biochemistry that
could be utilized in cellular machines
and on top of all of that the form of
these biorobots all resemble existing
organisms
that's not necessarily a bad thing but
what useful shapes and forms might exist
out there that we can't even imagine
we model machines based on creatures we
see around us because it would be
impossible to predict the behavior of
some totally random configuration
that is until now
enter the xenobot
xenobots were born out of a goal to make
an entirely biological robot with no
artificial components
a robot built from the ground up using
only animal cells taking shape not based
on any existing life form but in a
totally novel configuration
and it all starts with a frog embryo
after a frog egg is fertilized it forms
into a ball of stem cells
this clump of cells looks completely
uniform but in reality all of these
cells have a predetermined purpose
a fate of what they're meant to become
the cells on top generally become
epidermis or part of the central nervous
system the cells in the middle form the
muscles and the cells on the bottom form
the endoderm which leads to the
development of organs
these different sections can be
disassembled into their different
components and then reassembled in a new
arrangement
this d and reconstruction is done
entirely by hand using forceps the
desired sections of the embryo are
removed then basically mushed back
together
they are then bathed in a media that
causes them to stick together and they
re-adhere into a sphere
then the spheres can be sculpted into
new shapes using a cauterizer the
formation of the bots is done by human
hands but the design isn't human at all
it comes instead from a complex
artificial intelligence
a program called voxcad creates a
virtual environment complete with
real-life simulations of physics like
gravity friction liquid physics and
surface tension
and in this environment are small cubes
called voxels that represent the cells
of a digital xenobot
different cubes represent different
real-life cell identities
in the beginning the researchers started
with just two cell types passive like
skin cells and contractile like cardiac
cells and they start with one objective
for the digital xenobot to move forward
the different cell cubes are then
combined in a random way by the ai and
then placed into an evolutionary
algorithm which can evolve the digital
xenobot over time creating iteration
after iteration until it displays the
desired behavior at first the algorithm
makes completely random designs
these digital bots don't exhibit any
interesting behaviors beyond just sort
of wiggling a bit
but after many thousands of generations
eventually the algorithm will produce a
digital xenobot with the desired
behavior moving forward
the final design of the first digital
xenobot was a little blob with leg-like
appendages that it could use to scuttle
in a walking-like motion
the scientists then make the xenobot in
the lab with the same configuration
sticking the correct cells together and
sculpting it into the right shape and
sure enough when placed in their aquatic
petri dish the bots started walking and
when placed in an orientation facing to
the right they generally always walked
to the right as hoped the ai quite
accurately predicted the way that the
bots would move
the pink lines show the movement that
the ai predicted and the blue lines show
the actual movement of the xenobots
with this predictable movement the next
step was to put the xenobots to the test
to see if they could move through varied
environments
in mazes ranging from wide open fields
to tubes as small as half a nanometer in
diameter smaller than the diameter of a
human capillary
in all cases the zenobots followed the
path provided by the environment
traditional robots would have a lot of
trouble navigating something this small
but the xenobots could do so with ease
soon different types of locomotion were
created in the bots including bots with
small cilia that beat giving forward
motion
these ones like to spin in circles
the scientists also noticed that if they
injured the xenobots after about 10
minutes the wounds would close and the
bots would heal up researchers are still
working to understand the intricacies of
this but it appears that self-healing is
a built-in feature of these biobots
where contraction at the wound site can
help close the injuries
propelling themselves along and healing
the xenobots were already making waves
in the scientific community as a
revolutionary biohybrid
but as all roboticists know sometimes
robots end up doing surprising things
without being programmed and without any
sense or communication organs the
xenobots spontaneously started to work
together collecting and organizing piles
of debris
how is such cooperation possible by
mindless little bots
a hint comes from a study done in 1999.
these are sensorless robots each with a
little scoop on its front designed
simply to drive around and in their
environment are many small discs the
robots don't know about any other robots
can't sense if they're touching anything
can't tell if they're actually touching
a disc but as it randomly drives around
by chance it will eventually start
pushing a disc
the robot can push one disc or maybe two
but if it comes across a pile of disks
the robot isn't strong enough to keep
pushing so it's forced to reposition
itself and let go inadvertently adding
its disk to the pile
over time therefore piles of the disks
spontaneously emerge
this is precisely what's happening with
the xenobots they simply push particles
by chance until they cannot which
spontaneously leads to organized piles
of the debris and even though it's a
mindless and uncoordinated act it could
be a powerful tool for us one day
scientists think this gathering behavior
could allow such bots to collect micro
plastics from ocean water or to clear
plaques from arteries in the human body
and this ability led scientists to think
what else could the xenobots aggregate
what else could they round up and make
little piles out of
this is where the zenobot story gets
properly freaky
first the scientists had the ai redesign
the xenobots to optimize for collecting
particles
the original sphere shape as you might
guess isn't so great for the collection
task
instead the computer suggested a c-shape
similar to pac-man which is highly
efficient at collecting loose particles
then the researchers added a compelling
material to the xenobot's environment
frog stem cells the raw material of a
xenobot
and as the scientists hoped the xenobots
dutifully swept them up into small piles
just like they did with random debris
and then something remarkable happened
the piles of cells turned into new
xenobots
there are many types of reproduction in
the world of organisms from sexual to
asexual from splitting to budding to
birth these processes all share one
common trait
they all come from the parent organism
one way or another
but what the xenobots did has never
before been observed in living organisms
it's called kinematic self-replication
and has only ever been observed in
certain molecules
it's the act of reproducing by moving
and compressing dissociated parts in the
environment
and although it's never been observed in
cellular life forms until now it's
possible it even played a role in the
origin of multicellular life on earth
and this ability in robotics could lead
to exponential utility over time
currently individual xenobots can live
for 10 days in an aqueous environment
without needing any outside food source
this is a good start but limits what a
zenobot could do in the real world
but if xenobot raw material could be
continually added to the environment it
could mean limitless generations of
xenobots which could be a real force for
good
along with clearing pollution one day
they could perhaps be programmed to
selectively pick up and move specific
cell types that we want to use in
regenerative medicine
aggregating the materials for a body to
regrow damaged tissues
researchers are now working to create
xenobots that have a working memory a
read write ability to record one bit of
information using a fluorescent marker
that indicates if they've experienced
something in their environment
this type of memory could help us detect
the presence of things like radioactive
contamination chemical pollutants drugs
or certain diseases
and perhaps most importantly by
understanding xenobots we start to
understand the plasticity of living
cells
freed of their evolutionary fate cells
could be capable of astounding things
they can walk they can swim they can
collect debris and reproduce the
question is what else might they be able
to do
as for whether or not these bots are
alive is still a matter of great debate
they are made out of living cells and
can reproduce
but are still very much machines
our minds like to try to categorize but
in reality we might need to accept that
xenobots occupy a space in between both
living and machine
for now xenobots are simple and lack
nervous systems but if future biobots
are capable of emotions feelings or pain
this quandary may need more serious
consideration
harnessing the power of biology will be
the driving force behind the next
century of technological developments
whether it's understanding the raw
ability of cells free of their
evolutionary fate or by analyzing the
products of 3.8 billion years of
evolution the natural world has the
answers we need
in our quest to beat cancer find
solutions to antibiotic resistance
respond to natural disasters or traverse
the toughest climates imaginable our
survival in the future relies on tapping
in to nature's genius
and in a brand new six part series on
curiosity stream you can explore this
cutting edge of science with the series
called evolve
this refreshing docu-series dives deep
into the emerging world of biomimicry
and whether the unique adaptations of
the animal world can truly help us to
find futuristic solutions to some of our
biggest problems
it's one of the best series on curiosity
stream
it looks at mesmerizing behaviors like
this water-gathering butt-in-the-air
behavior from a namibian sand beetle and
searches for some of earth's most
venomous creatures which may hold
important answers in medicine
curiosity stream is a great streaming
platform and now they've partnered with
us to offer an incredible deal by
signing up to curiosity stream you now
also get a subscription to nebula nebula
is a streaming platform made by me and
several other educational youtube
content creators it's a place where we
can upload our videos ad free and a
place where we can experiment with new
original content on nebula you can watch
brand new originals like real
engineering's battle of britain which
recently had its first episode drop if
ever there was a time for a history
lesson on world war ii now is definitely
it
the lads have really upped their game
with the animations voice acting and
storytelling and there are several more
episodes to come so by signing up at
curiositystream.com
real science you'll get a subscription
to
stream and a subscription to nebula for
just 14.79 for the entire year
signing up is also the best way to
support this channel and all of your
favorite educational content creators
and if you're looking for something else
to watch right now you can watch our
previous video about the invasion of the
cane toad or watch real engineering's
latest video the insane engineering of
the parker solar probe
you